welcome to this video playing hmm yeah
sometimes Dave Decker no I'm completely
screwing this up it probably is related
to chess some other sneaker this
nickname ok we have a French and he's
playing the standards here without a
forum it's not not a bad line
interesting way to play I don't know it
in so much detail f6 I think you can you
can also take with the Queen but this is
the normal way to proceed yeah long
castles this is an interesting way to go
hmm what has two ideas here I can try to
play form a blockade on the dark squares
in the center like when ye 5i can just
try to attack with g4 and wild moves hmm
yeah what's my idea this is one of them
one of the ideas b5 ok if he's pushing
the edge for maybe 95 coming now maybe I
should provide some cover two to e 60 k
means just pushing the edge phone
yeah well aged aged h6 i'll play g6
don't think this is too dangerous always
need to show some respect for this kind
of poem on h6 but still I don't think
it's it's own so much of a problem you
see threatening to to sacrifice hmm
possible possible okay but I better take
that and what now maybe simple move this
Bishop to b6 am just exchanging if I go
before now no no let's let's do this
first I don't think Bishop g6 is really
really working a move you need to be
aware of push up g6 takes h7 but I don't
think it's it's yet working this is
Bishop d7 also was played to cover a
full also that before pushes the light
back all the way to be one let's see
what he's doing I can also just play
Bishop b6 and exchange that which is not
too great but it's possible just to get
rid of this piece only 5 that is not
really bad Bishop on e5 not that what
else could you do we can try to to play
rock lift rook h3g 3 this kind of news
but why it's only sunday is a bit better
here
if not more the long thinking time is a
bit suspicious maybe is really
considering to take a g6 I don't see a
don't see it working uh-huh hmm
interesting yeah maybe he intends g5 9h
drive and then and then taking taking on
h5 this kind of idea now go before him
he can't play g5 maybe takes on c3 we
are but that's no that's not that's not
so so tracking even if I need to
sacrifice an exchange this is I think
justified like g5 I can take on c3
Bishop see 666 that's not not a big
issue I'm very very strong on the dark
squares after that ok let's consider is
there some some tactical move like
something on f 2 wheels could be what
about 94 94 is interesting Bishop takes
a form and like we g5 check is got f4
okay but look f2 if I just if I go look
f2 and then kareena this as possible you
should reform group f to Queen moves and
then Cree g5 and takes on e5 and I'm
winning hmm it can maybe play rook t2
but I can take that seems to be okay and
I'm threatening Queen g5 anyway
and of course I'm threatening yeah okay
let's let's first take here the Sun the
only move anyway and now next Queen g5
check I don't see why not really so
there's some some crazy tactical idea if
he goes Queen d3h looks normal I might
even have Bishop b5 but okay Queen g5
check looked into the only critical try
I can just take you five yeah this is
working there's no one special special
trick for white and that's also know
kind of crazy and tech like yeah and now
just to check in check rook t2 i mean
the Bishop c5 on c5 is discovering the
rook okay so here just take take on g5
right yeah why not not even Bishop g6 is
dangerous maybe maybe it is dangerous
Bishop takes hg Queen takes King edge
aight where there is no there is no
immediate mate but um yeah yeah I have
lots of snot not so easy
hmm some way to to ignore that maybe
play for a counter-attack or get the
Queen's off something like that is
possible I don't know take screen takes
King edge aight i always have queen of
six I don't really see them I don't
really see a white catalyst if it plays
rook to e1 I have Queen f6 and the don't
think it's got time for for big prep
moves like an orgy five or something I
have worked yet getting the Queen out of
my camp droopy one Queen f6 should also
be quite safe maybe I am threatening
rook takes and t2 here followed by Queen
f4 going for for the tech maybe yeah the
Queen has no no real promising square
what about the caption now routine takes
Queen f4 check yeah probably needs to go
to d1 and I like I like this I like this
Bishop here the opportunity he does not
have mmm should we eat I'm playing
slowly god it's really unnecessary to do
so it's a fairly fairly easy now yeah
you should activate it here so it cannot
even move the night on the two happiest
almost white forfeits on time yeah
interesting I do know this was a bit out
of the blue 94 but it seemed to seem to
lead to too good
game let's have a look at that I mean
I've around here I'm a bit skeptical
about my position I think white should
should be okay the computer likes black
of interesting but with Bishop b6 ah
yeah this is a good north maybe i forgot
i come i didn't really appreciate that
this is hanging so wyd of course cannot
take relief check giving up the bishop
parent leaving this night stranded so
this would have been much better but you
near the computer likes black amazing I
really thought that what should have
something this looks a bit dangerous
this pawn ok this happened and now
before its winning already am so okay I
am ok very interesting is that I am on
g5 I mentioned the the exchange sec here
which is okay probably at least I think
so but the comp just wants to move the
night and wins yeah this is much easier
of course I don't know if I would have
played that it's much easier due to the
attack on f2 and the night I mean needs
to save itself there is no there is no
brilliant technical stroke him he needs
to retreat and then I'll just take that
with the insufficient compensation for
white and this is what I wanted to do
but it's it's probably worse in
comparison have this kind of position
like that this a thought should be quite
good for black at least it's it's a
decent compensation in a practical game
I've got at the moment I've got six
points against force or two pawns he
might get a sick so I can take a 16 but
his king is not secured an interesting
position I've got to bishop this is very
strong yeah but the other
other line is of course much better and
after night be 194 Black is just just
winning fled out looking to check yeah
Bishop b5 is also good but this is the
easiest check yeah we never 6 just keeps
the critical square protected and here a
bishop d-force even more forceful but ok
it's it's just the wind I mean like as a
piece of it has the attack okay thanks
for watching